for me the secret of a great brunch
is fun and casual fuss-free cooking and
everyone helping themselves
this is the ultimate steak sandwich you
want the rolls royce
of beef it has to be fill it now
season it beautifully i like to open up
the top of the peppermill to increase
the size of the pepper in the steak so
it gives that
bit of heat nice little chunks
you just roll now nicely all the way
around
now slice the garlic in half
pan nice and hot olive oil in
hold the steak and just place it into
the pan don't drop it
at the front of the pan we're going to
tilt the pan forward
cook the back of the steak dual purpose
now
roll it back and sear underneath
next my garlic and roast that garlic
thyme fry that time i want to hear it
we're not looking for a lot of color
because you're going to dry out the fill
it so just
one end turn it back down
and steer the other end in
lift up your time place it on top of the
garlic
there lift up your fillet and sit there
on
top of your garlic butter in
take a spoon tilt the pan gently
lift up and baste
i've got that scented garlic thyme
flavour
the steak is going to cook evenly
because it's sat on a little
a little bed in the oven for eight to
ten minutes
[Music]
pan on for the relish you think of a
steak sandwich you think of a
sort of nice heated tomato relish
to make the relish finely dice a red
onion three finger rule
one in front two behind
through and chop wow
next roughly chop a chilli keeping the
seeds in for extra heat
start off with the olive oil into a pan
onions chilis
[Music]
generous with the olive oil i want a
nice sort of
rich silky relish
on there take your tomatoes
you can't just use red tomatoes but
these yellow
and red make the perfect combination now
put your salt in pepper
and then roast those tomatoes off
take a wooden spoon and just sort of
break them up once the skins blister
the whole tomato just starts to release
all that really nice
sweet texture a little teaspoon of
cherry vinegar
gives that nice acidic balance the
sweetness
of the tomatoes turn down the gas and
just let them sort of
stew perfectly now a steak sandwich
would not be complete
unless it had the most amazing mustard
mayonnaise
simply add three tablespoons of
mayonnaise to three teaspoons of whole
grain mustard
[Music]
now i've got the reddish almost down to
like a really nice jam
now i want to make that relish a little
bit more fragrant
some basil slice it through
sprinkle that basil in there
[Music]
beautiful
look at this
there she is my crown jewels
time to take it out
smell is incredible
just based one more time
to fill it
touch is quite soft in the center so
it's just coming up to mid-rare let it
rest
at the same time you cooked it it'll be
nice and pink
evenly throughout the steak to make my
sandwich
i'm going to char grill some sliced
chipatta bread season it nicely
just a little drizzle of olive oil i
want to get that bread nice and crispy
pan nice and hot bread
in push it down smell is amazing that
char
sort of charcoal flavor once you've got
those marks on the bread
it just stops the bread from becoming
soggy and look at this here
it is stunning on
slice it gently
one beautiful slice
wow it's nice and pink
all the way through and the beef is so
soft it's almost like slicing through
butter let the knife do the work
take a little bit of mayonnaise spread
that
the back of the spoon on both sides
next lettuce take that
beautiful slice of beef
and then relish on top of that beef
and just slice the sandwich in half
beautiful now that's what i call a steak
sandwich
trust me serve the sublime sandwich for
brunch and you'll put a smile on
everyone's face
[Music]
the great thing about brunch is there
are no rules the only thing i insist on
are
it's got to be fuss-free easy to cook
and so delicious
it puts you in a good mood for the rest
of the day
and for me pancakes always hit the spot
here are three of my deliciously
different recipes
certified to liven up your mornings
first up
fluffy blueberry and ricotta pancakes
with yogurt
start by adding 125 grams of plain flour
a teaspoon of baking powder a pinch of
salt
a tablespoon of sugar then create a wet
in the center
separate two eggs and add the yolks
keeping the whites for later
beat the yolks into the flour pouring in
milk gradually
to form a smooth batter
[Music]
next fold in 125 grams of creamy ricotta
cheese
and 100 grams of fresh blueberries
[Music]
now whisk your egg whites into the
almost reach soft peaks
then gently fold into the pancake mix
keep it in the air
to make sure the pancakes are extra
light and really fluffy
add olive oil and butter into a hot pan
then spoon in the mix to make small
pancakes
cooking until golden brown on both sides
to finish top with greek yoghurt fresh
blueberries
and drizzle over lovely runny honey
sweet savory fruity and delicious made
in 15 minutes
perfect brunch pancakes
my second simple pancake brunch recipe
is
succulent crab and mascarpone crepes
[Music]
for the filling put cooked white crab
meat into a bowl
add in mascarpone the zest and juice of
a lemon
finely chopped chives and for a spicy
hit cayenne pepper
stir and set aside
for the pancake batter simply add flour
salt an egg
and milk then whisk into a smooth
mixture
add oil to a hot nonstick pan ladle in
batter
to cover the bottom and swirl it around
spreading out nice and thinly
when lovely and golden flip over turn
out
and spoon the delicious crab mix into
the center of the pancake and roll
finally sprinkle with some chopped
chives and devour
my second pancake recipe crab and
mascarpone crepes a fantastic easy
brunch
cooked in minutes
[Music]
when you want your pancakes sweet and
zingy this recipe is perfect
coconut pancakes with mango and lime
syrup
for the lime syrup simply add water cast
the sugar
possess the juice of the lime and simmer
for 10 minutes
to make the easy pancake batter put
flour baking powder
and desiccated coconut into a bowl then
crack in an egg
add coconut milk and whisk into the
batter
until well combined sweeten with runny
honey
now you're ready to fry add melted
butter to a hot pan
place in heaped teaspoons of batter flip
and cook until golden for a lovely
vibrant wake up
so with sliced fresh mango and drizzle
over the gorgeous citrusy syrup
sweet sticky and utterly irresistible
ready in under 20 minutes
the ultimate indulgent pancakes
you